here's a good story for you that
Scorsese told me when we were making the
Departed I brought up the king of comedy
which is one of my favorites of his
that's an all-time most polarizing movie
right he goes I was putting on a tuxedo
I was going out to a New Year's Eve
party and the television was on the
entertainment Reporter Goes and the
competition for the worst movie of the
year is over the king of comedy and
Marty said he just tied his bow tie and
he sat and he just looked at himself in
the mirror and then untied the boat
[Music]
you know keep a lot of people here it
was a big screen theater in L.A instead
of 86 I think from Barry London only a
few of us were there some people
well-known people
in terms of the originality was that
original you go into it because it's a
matter of the risk taking that's so
unique and so powerful that uh
[Music]